la parole est maintenant président
michel magras pour le groupe l'est
républicain
donner la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mais à
notre délégation à l'outre-mer a été
alertée par les professionnels du sucre
de la réunion de la menace de plus en
plus pressante que fait peser sur la
filière canne la politique commerciale
européenne différentiel de compétitivité
fin des quotas sucriers en 2017 et
accumulation des accords commerciaux met
en grave danger la philly à cannes cette
filière qui fait partie du patrimoine de
nous sommes représentent près de 40000
emplois directs et indirects dans les
territoires sinistrés par les taux de
chômage record
c'est l'équivalent de trois millions
d'emplois pour l'hexagone
il est impensable de laisser la
commission européenne sacrifier les
économies de nos rup sur l'hôtel du
libre échange et de laisser prospérer
une politique commerciale en
contradiction totale avec les politiques
régionales et agricoles à quoi sert
d'octroyer l'autorisé des aides qui ont
permis une modernisation vertueuse de la
filière si on l'a pris parallèlement de
débouchés en encourageant une
concurrence à bas coût sur les marchés
européens
je sais votre mobilisation est celle des
services en charge du suivi des
négociations en cours avec le vietnam
cependant l'accord politique intervenu
cet été sonne comme un coup de semonce
pour la production sucrière des rup
comment peut-on découvrir au coeur du
mois d'août que l'accord politique a été
finalisée s'en aller at préalable des
autorités françaises
le mandat de négociation données en
amont à la commission at il était
suffisamment cadrée
quelles garanties peut-on désormais
espérer alors que de nombreux autres
accords commerciaux se profile déjà
voilà un ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président ma gras comme je viens de le
dire c'est vrai c'est un problème qui
agite beaucoup aujourd'hui les économies
d outre-mer puisque nous connaissons
l'importance de la filière canne rome
pour ces pays
vous savez que cet accord concernant
l'union européenne et le vietnam résulte
d'un héritage que nous avons dû régler
en tout cas assumer d'une manière qui
n'étaient pas suffisamment anticipé le
mandat qui a été donné à la commission
européenne de négociation ne prévoyait
pas cette question de des outre-mer par
conséquent nous sommes obligés d'essayer
de nous infiltrer pour faire entendre à
la commission européenne
la difficulté que pose pour les outre
mer la cette négociation en cours
par conséquent nous avons toutefois
obtenu une avancée positive puisque
comme je l'indiquais haut à madame
hervio nous avons obtenu l'exclusion de
l'accord en cours de la principale ligne
tarifaire d'exportation des sucres
ultramarins mais c'est vrai que ça
aurait été plus simple si précédemment
la commission européenne avait été
alerté sur cette question alors que là
nous nous inviterons un peu dans un
débat en cours d'une manière un peu
difficile ceci dit le savez que nous
mettons tous les moyens pour essayer
d'avancer et par exemple nous avons donc
bien prévu pour les futurs accords qui
seront négociées par exemple ce qui est
en cours avec l'afrique du sud
nous avons bien prévu exclusion des
sucres spéciaux
par ailleurs comme nous l'avons indiqué
aussi nous sommes en train de négocier
actuellement nous allons déposer auprès
de la commission européenne
l'autorisation d'augmenter les aides de
l'état a à la filière canne sucre de 38
millions d'euros
le dossier a été préparé en liaison avec
les organisations professionnelles et
par conséquent il est étayée aujourd'hui
nous pouvons le déposer mais vous savez
qu'il y à d'autres difficultés
exemple nous avons reçue c'est louis
pour le raffinage du sucre qui ne se
fera plus par conséquent nous sommes à
l'oeuvre et nous travaillons vraiment
pour sauvegarder le sucre d outre mer
compte tenu de l'importance de cette
filière que nous connaissons bien sûr le
président magra pour bon 20 secondes et
madame la ministre et outre-mer la
stratégie actuelle de la france semble
avoir atteint ses limites
la délégation sénatoriale outre-mer du
sénat s'est saisi de cette question et
propose à proposer ce matin à
l'unanimité une proposition de
résolution qui vous proposera une
dizaine de préconisations aussi clair
que précise qui nous semble
indispensable de mettre en place si nous
voulons sauver les économies des rup au
nom des rup
nous attendons du gouvernement est de la
france une action plus ferme pour être
plus efficace et monsieur le président
pour les régions ultrapériphériques